[Music]
johnny depp officially joins tick tock
and dedicates his first video to fans
who supported him during his six-week
trial do you find that mr depp has
proven all the elements of defamation
answer yes
about a week after winning his
defamation suit against ex-wife amber
hurd johnny is moving on he took to
social media with the love letter to
loyal and unwavering fans he captioned
the clip in part we have walked the same
road together we did the right thing
together all because you cared and now
we will all move forward together a ton
of those fans followed the trial on tick
tock clips like this going viral on the
app i'm not seeking any 15 minutes here
though you may you're welcome to
speculate i could say the same thing by
taking amber hurt as a client for you
a little argumentative don't you think
oh hardly
and we already know how amber feels
about johnny leaning into the social
media following he built during the
trial her rep tells e.t as johnny depp
says he's moving on women's rights are
moving backward the verdict's message to
victims of domestic violence is be
afraid to stand up and speak out johnny
doesn't follow anyone on tick-tock yet
but he already has over 4 million
followers and counting in his bio the
pirates of the caribbean star calls
himself an occasional thespian as for
getting back to acting a source tells
e.t johnny is looking forward to his
career future 30 years ago i would have
told
i think i would have told that version
of me what what i told myself then which
was you know
um
find out where
where you want to be
you know and uh and get there
because at the time
i wanted to be able to
rep i i didn't want to represent
what that was all about i wanted i
wanted to be a character actor the
moonlight shows us for what we really
are
that's interesting while it remains to
be seen when johnny will be back on the
big screen he does appear to be focused
on music these days
[Music]
he even gave his loyal fans a look
inside his creative process in that
first tick tock taking cameras inside
the recording studio as he preps for a
performance
before and after his court victory the
58 year old has been rocking out on tour
with guitarist jeff beck in the uk
[Music]
if i've gained if i've gained some
degree of success in this industry i'm
really it's it's been it's been very
it's been very good to me it's been very
good for me
[Music]